250 000
that was incredible
it didn't cost quite that much but at
112 000 pounds still incredible for a
makeover that's the sum boris johnson
got from a tory donor to do up his
private flat 18 months ago
thank you today at a vaccine center in
northampton trying to move on from that
episode as more embarrassing details
surfaced into how he came by a
six-figure sum which was later forced to
repay he was accused of undermining
trust in government by failing to hand
over embarrassing private messages
between him and the donor the prime
minister unrepentant i followed the
ministerial guidance at all times
in november 2020 the pm whatsapp's tori
donor lord brownlow that he is afraid
parts of his downing street flat are
still a bit of a tip and he is keen to
allow lulu little a designer to get on
with refurbishments
of course lord brandley replies get lulu
to call me and we'll get it sorted asap
before adding approval is a doddle as
it's only me and i know where the money
will come from so as soon as lula calls
me we can crack on
ethics adviser lord guide was initially
told these exchanges never happened but
when a separate investigation uncovered
their existence he nearly quit today in
an exchange of letters lord geit said
the new messages did not alter his
fundamental assessment that the pm had
not misled him but said the failure of
officials to offer up the messages in
the first place shook my confidence in
the system boris johnson replied
offering a humble and sincere apology
boris johnson was cleared today because
he managed to convince his ethics
advisor that he had no idea that the
tory donor he was asking for help with
the flat refurbishment would also end up
writing the checks for it
but he did know that tory dunner wanted
something help setting up a new great
exhibition and when he asked for cash he
offered to help with that
everybody wants favors from a prime
minister but the wealthy aren't meant to
be top of the key for them i think there
were really big questions to ask about
what exactly the prime minister was
promising that conservative donor and
why he seemed to be spending time as the
prime minister
supporting the pet project of a
conservative donor
lulu little's extravagant taste here and
now also on display in downing street
but with favors for donors and
inconvenient evidence buried can boris
johnson really draw the rather expensive
curtains in this affair sam coates sky
news